hey guys I'm just eight days thursday
and a whole bunch of things happened in
gaming today for all the ones I wasn't
able to cram in today's episode be sure
to subscribe to us on YouTube but here's
the rest first up for those of you who
were none too pleased with mass effect
Andromeda's animations by we have
released a statement the dev team posted
a statement to Twitter which said that
the studio has received quite a bit of
feedback both positive and negative x
where explained that feedback is an
important part of our ongoing support of
the game and we can't wait to share more
of our immediate plans with you on
Tuesday April fourth the studio also
added that the team is listening and
working around the clock to gather
information and plan out solutions to
improve and build on Andromeda
unfortunately you like us or we'll need
to wait until April floor to find out
what those mysterious plans are that
stay tuned to games but and we'll make
sure you're in the loop destiny fans
will be happy today as we finally have
concrete details on destiny too and I'm
happy because the game is finally coming
to PC yeah but we're gonna play on ps4
Tim it alongside the game to reveal
trailer Bungie has announced that an
open beta is coming to all platforms
this summer that's pc xbox one and ps4
destiny to will arrive officially on sep
tember 8 just like we suspected bungees
premise for the game is super long so
I'm gonna try and boil it down humanity
had one last safe city which is fall
into the red Legion as led by Gul Gul we
would call who in the process of being a
douchebag also took all the powers away
from the city's Guardians so you've got
a venture across new worlds and find new
weapons and abilities to ultimately take
this dude out Angie I'm available for
any writing opportunities I'll expect
your call destiny to will also have a
season pass called the expansion pass
that will give you access to the first
two expansions which include new story
missions cop activities competitive
multiplayer and so on you'll also need
to choose between several different
editions of the game depending on how
many dollars you want to throw at it
some additions include premium content
collectible items or a messenger bag if
that's what you need in your life check
out the full list of what's included in
each edition in our story on gabe's
lives the Nintendo switches digital
library has grown a little today with
the addition of a new game on the eshop
metal slug has joined other classic
arcade games like king of fighters to
bring the number of neo geo titles
available on the Nintendo switch a shop
up to nine for those of you who don't
know metal slug is a running gun shooter
that's as fun as it is brutally
difficult you can pilot things like
tanks and camels while dodging enemies
and rescuing POWs in exotic locations
you can grab it on the eshop right now
for eight bucks if arcade classics
aren't your thing try and develop a
frozen bite strategy RPG husband Heroes
is now available as well as the indie
platformer snake pass let me know down
below what you're going to pick up for
your switch or if zelda is still keeping
you busy that is everything I've got for
you today to have yourself a lovely day
or evening wherever you are in the world
we shall i head to gamespot for our
persona 5 review and come back same time
tomorrow for our top 5 news of the whole
week I'll see you then